so it was revealed in keeping up with
kardashians that kim kardashian did not
in fact
pass the baby bar exam i covered this
story uh two years ago kim kardashian is
trying to become a lawyer in california
through a little used apprenticeship
program
she's not going to an accredited law
school she's trying to become a lawyer
by being an apprentice for other lawyers
and as part of that process you have to
take the baby bar exam this is the thing
in california where if you don't go to
an accredited law school or you're using
this apprenticeship thing
you have to take a test to make sure
that you are up to snuff so that you can
continue
and not waste everyone's time and money
she came relatively close but
didn't actually pass and i applaud her
for putting in the hard work it would be
really easy for a celebrity like her to
just completely phone it in
it seems like she's being genuine and i
imagine she could do a lot of good for
criminal justice reform if she were able
to pass the bar
so i'm rooting for kim to take the baby
bar exam again and continue
in her studies